so so Daniel David talk a little bit
about some of the creative changes that
you've made to the pilot that we saw
this is I think a world premiere of the
brand-new version of the pilot what you
guys change at the end basically I mean
one of the good things about the pilot
process is you get a chance to regroup
and originally in the pilot we have a
character named live which is a
character that wasn't in the comic books
that we created as daniel said she was
sort of she was very reactive and
wide-eyed and and and I felt like she
couldn't really go toe-to-toe with John
and so when we stand around and we
started talking about the dead character
from the comic books he's got a really
interesting backstory once it was in the
first time and you know I know another
thing that you guys saw that's sort of a
person only gonna be seen again I know
the pilot leaked online and there was a
different sort of demon and you know
what happened is it was a like we really
wanted to present a certain reality to
the show we wanted to be around in
reality that was scary and we ended up
and really driven into kind of CGI world
with the team and that was on the prep
table if we thought you know David and I
really nobody was pushing us a reshoot
that sequence like - but Dave never like
you know what we just want this to be as
compelling and real aliens
so we thought what better way than a
basic universe himself
that was fun through Matt to go in and
surgically shoe you know that one piece
of the grip top right gotta go bad and
even interested me well it was really
fun to play to play the diamond job
first of all then to kind of played
against myself but I wasn't actually
that was a whole other experience so can
i I mean come on the guy is John
Constantine
dude but here's the amazing thing about
it you have to understand we saw him he
was on stage of to claw henry v and we
get this we literally read and mess with
in terms of people and we get the self
tape in we're like you know my hair is
hairy feet back beard
so man how did you how did you sort of
been funded to a Constantine what made
you go after us I mean the first of all
I'm reading the script that they're the
guys who produced was great and then I
have a friend of mine who was a huge
comic book fan and for years he's been
telling me about John Constantine and
Hal blazer and I didn't really know
about much about it and then I told him
that I was I was auditioning he was
really serious names like right this is
how you do it get these emails going
then you get this signal that you get in
that and you know and that's he's my own
personal critic so he's happy a few
comics I started reading those and then
went through the audition process and
then and then after I got the job I just
kind of delved into the comics you know
and with all the source material that's
there I mean it's great because you know
you can just keep finding
hey why don't you talk a little bit
about embodying Mary and what it was
like to join Constantine to say you know
when I talk to these guys they told me
they were going to create Manny for the
for the show I thought it was a really
great opportunity to be on the ground
floor of something new to the you know
to the constantina
the world and so I'm not sure that I
fully invited here because I'm still
learning more about Italy they won't
tell me everything about it
it's mighty skill to embody others
we have Weibo to tell whether they
exciting we keep coming up with new
things and figuring out you know the
type of angel you don't know if you're
good or bad yeah yeah what the great
things about the Mannings characters you
know in the comic you have those panels
where you really get into John
Constantine's thoughts we're not really
a voiceover show will have little
snippets of it here and there but what's
nice about the Manny character is he's
able to talk to John and ready access
sort of explore what it means because
they kind of you know they both kind of
manipulating each other but this is kind
of mutual respect between them you know
they both know they can they can do some
ha but at the same time they both try to
get everyone up on each other so it's a
really interesting dynamic between we
still keep thinking of each other
gunslingers yeah and helico talked about
joining this this ragtag group and then
producers how are you gonna introduce
that it's a ride I've enjoyed right now
and I'm so excited to give a little bit
of a meetin both to Zed and to play with
this amazing cast and to play against
John Constantine she just filmed her
first day last night and when did you
get when did you finish last night I
finished at 4 o'clock in the morning
this morning we did a chemistry test
we've read a lot of chemistry tests with
mat and inhale again I swear she entered
a room she did she was back at him up
against y'all you know because of course
I'm Latinos I want to give a little take
love easily and what some people always
take it and when we smell BS
Charles I talked about during the show I
play jazz Jones best hit
longest-surviving drink a lot of miss
rings from had that luxury of surviving
he tends to lose a lot of friends for
the greater good and he also serves as
sort of a driving force not to say just
cabbie or driver but prodding this
certain morning's work job rather just
wake up and deal with his hangover
attend that cooking breakfast you're
gonna kick him in the gear
David you wanted to mention something
something that you're really proud of
about the show yeah I wanted to announce
that our composer is somebody that the
comic-con proud is probably very
familiar with Emmy winning composer very
query
atmospheric music they heard in the
pilot be hearing it on in the series
talk a little bit about what we should
expect this season how close they are
you going to align with the original the
original comic book series versus the
new 52 it sounds like they're going back
to above you people were going bold
weird you'll have brought the romantic
company and delighted you know musical
theatre look there were over 300 issues
over 300 inches tall blades or there's I
know a dozen 16 issues a constant view
with the new 52 so we're going to be
dipping into the Delano stuff the answer
Ella stop and then as the best writers
in the business of been writing
Constantine for the last 25 years and
we've used that as our source material
when Constance Depp didn't see the Swamp
Thing universe you know it was it was
shortly after the New Castle incident
Bernie Manzano blazer and that's the
point that we're meeting them as you've
seen from the pilot we use them for
heavy heavy inspiration and by the end
of the first season we're going to
introduce all of the new counsel crew
and reconstitute them in the season in
our climax but it's all it's all
directly from the earliest early stages
of Swamp Thing and in Hellblazer
all this pop I mean it's all I and all
the things that happen to Constantine
it's all ahead of them
so we have a chance to dramatize and
visualize all of it and just you know
not only have an advance
they can meet him anyone else he could
talk about you I went up and later the
seasons otama for example or okay we
have access to the sort of a call corner
of the DC Universe so you'll be seeing
some other characters filtering in we've
got probably our first guy in episode
five or six and a few others we just
want to make sure that it's not guest
star the week that they're occurring
characters is somebody that works and
organically but I'm sure many of you saw
the doctor fate helmet a clear
indication of our intentions all right
well unfortunately that is the end of
our panel so Constantine Fridays this
fall on end
you